bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique le scrutin des
élections régionales va se dérouler ce
dimanche en ile de france les derniers
sondages donnent la candidate les
républicains en tête au premier comme au
second tour mais rien n'est encore joué
de nombreux électeurs hésiteraient
encore et les scores du front national
et du parti socialiste et qui sont au
coude à coude au premier tour pourrait
fortement évolué vous entendrez au cours
de cette émission emmanuel lowen
bruxelles la tête de liste des de nous
citoyens qui se présentent dans l les
yvelines ce sera en seconde partie
d'émission mais tout de suite nous
retrouvons cet entretien enregistré il
ya quelques jours avec valeron de
saint-just le candidat tête de liste ile
de france du front national le parti de
marine le pen on les écoute c'était la
semaine dernière
je reçois à présent vallerand de
saint-just candidat du front national
tête de liste en ile-de-france bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes élu au conseil
régional de picardie vous avez été
secrétaire départemental de votre
formation dans la somme mais depuis
quelques années vous avez rejoint la
capitale vous avez été candidat lors des
municipales à paris
vous aviez enregistré un peu plus de 6%
des suffrages est donc aujourd'hui en
lice pour la région francilienne
pourquoi c'est arrivé ici sur cette
région francilienne vous que l'on
présente souvent comme l'inconnu du
front national vous étiez dans l'ombre
puisque avocats historiques de la
formation mais aussi encore aujourd'hui
son trésorier
pourquoi parce que j'ai toujours habité
la région parisienne et j ai travaillé
pendant 40 ans comme avocat mais j'ai
été faire de la politique
la nuit et les week-ends en province
enfin un mot sur votre parcours c'est la
première fois que nous recevons ici vous
êtes vous êtes vous corrigerez les
éventuelles erreurs mais catholiques
traditionalistes anti gaulliste
convaincu vous avez suivi les actions de
l'organisation étudiante d'extrême
droite groupe union défense le guide
dans vos jeunes années de ses jeunes
années justement il reste quoi
aujourd'hui
ce parcours que j'ai dressé briller dans
tivoli chevauchée j'ai dû bien un bien
grand mot souhaitait aussi très jeune un
de gaulle est mort j'avais 19 ans les
ffg forcé j'avais 12 ans j'habitais la
province d'ailleurs à l'époque donc que
je m'en souviens des années d'étudiant
eu un intérêt tout de suite pour la pour
la politique et une véritable formation
la part de professeurs notamment
moi j'ai fait pas mal de droit mais j'ai
fait aussi pas mal de l'histoire des
idées politiques et c'est ça qui me fait
presque le plus passionné et pourquoi
cette branche là pourquoi comment il
faut choisir un engagement politique il
faut choisir un parti politique pour en
tout cas écoutez moi ce que je sais
c'est que je ne suis pas de gauche
c'est au sens je suis pas socialiste
ce socialiste est bien défini c'est à
dire l'appropriation collective des
moyens de production
voyez d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
socialiste à ce sans sac et de sens
originel
donc je suis capitaliste et a presque
capitaliste par défaut alors on met des
étiquettes extrême droite droite gauche
et star je sais que je ne suis pas
socialiste je sais que je ne suis pas de
gauche
j'ai juste eu par relativiste au sens on
le dit assez souvent de la gauche et
donc j'ai pu et étiquetés à droite
peut-être même à l'extrême droite mais
les problèmes sont elles à l'heure
actuelle en france
on le voit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui tout
ce que nous avons nous mis en avant
depuis plusieurs années plusieurs
dizaines d'années c'est à dire le le
patriotisme l'amour de la france
le drapeau les couleurs bleu blanc rouge
c'est adopter à nouveau dans la douleur
c'est vrai mais adoptée à nouveau par
une très grande partie de nos
compatriotes
enfin le front national n'a pas le
monopole du drapeau bleu blanc ou julien
tout pas du tout mais il a il l'a
ramassé un peu dans le caniveau là où
ils traînaient notamment après mai mai
1968 pendant des années des années
le front national a essayé et l'a mis
sur le devant de la scène
les patriots étaient nous le bleu blanc
rouge c'était nous si serré adoptées
maintenant par une grande partie non
seulement de la classe politique mais de
nos compatriotes s'il le maître vraiment
même symboliquement comme ce matin à la
fenêtre de tout temps maison que nous en
sommes très heureux
on va parler de votre programme est déjà
justement les derniers sondages imagine
que vous avez regardé avec attention
on vous crédite de 25% au second tour en
troisième position derrière valérie
pécresse et claude bartelone vous êtes
le seul parti on va dire à progresser
clairement après les attentats oui on
aurait beaucoup je souhaitais que ses
attentes année n'ait pas lieu
mais puisqu'ils ont eu lieu que vous me
posez la question il faut bien dire que
nous avons le sentiment et avec beaucoup
de français que ces attentats sont un
peu le résultat d'un laxisme généralisé
d'état depuis des dizaines d'années ils
ont des causes notamment des causes
politiques internes française
extrêmement importante
et puis les français se rendre compte
que nous avons toujours fait donc les
bonnes analyses
dénoncer les vrais dangers et essayer
d'apporter des propositions et des
solutions qui pourraient être maintenant
efficace compte tenu de la situation
vous vous êtes fait remarquer juste
après les attentats par un tweet vous
avez dénoncé les responsabilités de vos
concurrents ps europe écologie aussi
dans ces actes meurtriers de paris et de
son nid je sais qu'on vous fait beaucoup
encore réagir aujourd'hui sur ces
déclarations parce que j'y mets vous
justement la question mais oui c'est
qu'on nous présente les assassins
souvent comme des fanatisés et même des
drogués bon c'est une chose la
responsabilité politique morale et
intellectuelle de ceux qui sont en haut
je ceux qui ont de l'influencé
médiatique la science tout court et d'
influence médiatique qui dirige cette
responsabilité est à mon sens
extrêmement importante
elle vous me parlez que barton et des
mac os mais que dire de valérie pécresse
qui de façon presque plus hypocrite
claude bartolone et mac os va s'allier
avec lui dit et le bad m avec notamment
madame jouanno qui eux il ya un mois ont
voté pour les subventions aux
clandestins proposées par monsieur
huchon conseil régional 1 pécresse a
voté quoi tous les clandestins ne sont
pas terroristes vous avez dit il ya une
responsabilité morale publique
considérable jeu plus importante que
celle des assassins cieux il ya eu 130
morts et 300 blessés
vendredi 13 novembre premièrement
deuxièmement nous savons que des
terroristes sont passés par la filière
des clandestins et on s'en doutait le
même l'état islamique avait et il avait
annoncé je suis dur de la part de ces
organisations terroristes faire passer
leurs agents de cette façon là c'était
évident troisièmement j'incrimine donc
tout ce qui facilite d'une manière ou
d'une autre
l'arrivée de ces clandestins en europe
et en france et madame pécresse qui est
alliée de façon hypocrite avec les gens
du pays de bade m qui sont totalement
contraires avec elle sur ces sujets
aussi importants est aussi symbolique
aujourd'hui et au moins d'une très
grande hypocrisie
quoi qu'il advienne le front national va
réaliser un score historique en france
et en ile de france parce qu'aujourd'hui
au conseil régional vous n'avez pas
telus pour le front national lui ont plu
et et vous en aurez forcément si l'on en
croit les résultats des différents
sondages
quels seront vos objectifs si les
sondages se concrétise dans les urnes et
que vous êtes dans l'opposition comment
vous allez poser dans l'opposition notre
objectif c'est que nous serons la
véritable opposition
je les ai vus parce qu'on a aiguillé
quand même le fonctionnement de cette
mandature
il ya une véritable ya toujours une
véritable connivence entre madame
pécresse et monsieur jean paul huchon
c'est ça le est d'ailleurs le fait
qu'elle est votée il ya il ya encore un
ou deux ans la proposition de jean paul
huchon pour le transport gratuit des
clandestins en ile de france montre
cette connivence et cette connivence
pouvait exister parce qu'il n'y avait
pas d'élus du front national élu à la
région avec les mémés mais mes amis mes
camarades nous serons la vraie
proposition et nous empêcherons madame
pécresse avec la la la la la fausse
gauche et les faux écologistes je les
empêcheront de nuire au temps qu'ils ont
nuit pendant la précédente mandature et
vous serez présent vous aller siéger en
fin de semaine dernière je vois sourire
mais les journalistes de france
télévisions qui publiait les résultats
d'une enquête sur l'assiduité des élus
vous seriez le moins présente la région
un mail gardy entre 2010-2015 vous
auriez même eu 22 1800 euros de
pénalisation du monte et que tu es on me
dit ça depuis battant souvent ça
ressemble et j'assume enfin j'assume
j'aurais préféré être présent et je
trouve que depuis deux ans et plus un
problème j'ai toujours été présent
conservé un groupe car dit mais j'ai eu
des responsabilités professionnelles
extrêmement importante je suis pas un
professionnel de la politique je gagne
ma vie comme je travaille et j'ai dû
être assez souvent absent c'est vrai là
on conseillera de picardie les absences
professionnelles ne sont pas admises
tandis qu'au conseil rénale de paris et
d'ile-de-france pardon elles sont admis
c'est parfaitement marqué dans le
silence des jalles vous serez absent non
avait des obligations professionnelles
et politiciens professionnels qui font
ça toute la journée
moi jusqu'à l'année dernière puisque
maintenant j'ai pris ma retraite de deux
d'avocats jusqu'à l'année dernière
j'avais une activité professionnelle
extrêmement prenante
il fallait que je fasse les deux en même
temps vous dites cette affaire ressort
vous mener une campagne difficile parce
que vous êtes aussi mis en examen dans
la sphère du micro-parti de jeanne c'est
le micro parti du fond
sionnel qui est poursuivi pour
escroquerie acceptation par un parti
politique d'un financement par une
personne morale c'était pour les
législatives de 2012
les affaires qui sortent comme ça
pendant la campagne on a vu de la
campagne par le plus vous vous en
reparler mais bon j'ai il faut voir les
conditions de la mise en examen ça a été
un peu rocambolesque que parce que tout
le monde s'est trompé
je suis je crois que le métier de
trésorier d'un parti politique d'un
métier dangereux et moi c'est
opérationnel recel de produits d'abus de
biens sociaux est un peu ésotérique est
incompréhensible en plus un jour
vraiment je montrerai que le dossier est
complètement vide
on va s'intéresser au programme pour la
suite de cet entretien vous annoncer
clairement les choses vos mesures ne
pourront s'appliquer que si marine le
pen gagne en 2017
même si vous êtes élu vous n'aurez pas
les coûts des fonds non mais si j'étais
plus de caricatures
si vous voulez reprenons un sujet qui
est extrêmement prégnant à l'heure
actuelle ces deux sujets de la politique
de la ville des 200 quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
à travers l'île de france où nous savons
et tout le monde le dit et le ministre
kaner l'a d'ailleurs dit ce matin
l'islamisme radical est comme un poisson
dans l'eau
il faut dans ces quartiers-là reprendre
tout à la base que ce soit des questions
d'éducation est question et services
publics et questions de sécurité
question de présence policière est
question de justice d'application de la
règle de droit de la règle pénale il
faut tout reprendre à la base la région
a des pouvoirs pour la version wii la
région a une compétence importante dans
la politique de la ville est là à mon
avis une responsabilité très importante
dans la destruction de tous ses
quartiers depuis 20 ou 30 ans mais il
est clair que la région tout seul
n'avait que ses compétences ne pourra
pas vraiment renverser la vapeur
ça sera le ministre de l'éducation
nationale se sera mis un tel ça sera
demi soit de la justice qui devront
oeuvrer pour que premièrement la vie
redevienne plus harmonieuse parce que je
sais comment nos compatriotes vivent
dans ces quartiers sur vraiment
fermement et durablement et que la
sécurité revienne et que l'islamisme
radical soit éradiquer définitivement de
tous ces quartiers mais la première
mesure que vous prendriez si vous êtes
élu justement dans le cadre de la
sécurité
qui aujourd'hui fait d'inquiétudes j'ai
dis parce que là c'est la sécurité dans
les transports qui inquiète beaucoup nos
concitoyens à l'heure actuelle parce que
des attentats dans les transports sont
fréquents et pourrait être à l'heure
actuelle facile au père et nous avons
prévu de financer c'est tout à fait
possible avec la ratp la sienne chef par
l'intérieur du stif la présence de deux
gardes armés dont gérard les gars fort
pour faire baisser la fraude berthe
bêcher d'abord l'insécurité et en même
temps la fraude puisque ya des chiffres
qui montrent la présence de deux gardes
armés comme ça pendant quatre ou cinq
heures dans une grande gare du rer dans
la banlieue nord a fait baisser a fait
acheter plus 80% de billets pendant
cette période là voilà donc ça serait
une mesure immédiate et qui par les
mesures de l'économique nous avons
préconisé serait parfaitement faisable
aujourd'hui est nécessaire mesures
d'économies justement programme
d'amaigrissement de 2% pour 2016 des
dépenses de la région pas pour 2016
chaque année chaque année en d'état
mandature par principe 2% donc ça veut
dire on va ajouter de l'austérité à la
politique de la vérité la simple vérité
d'austérité sas à faire des bonnes
économies sur de mauvaises dépenses pour
faire baisser d'abord la fiscalité et
deuxièmement remettre de l'argent dans
les programmes que nous jugeons
prioritaire bon si on n'est pas d'accord
avec mes priorités on ne vote pas pour
moi mais j'ai des priorités qui sont
notamment l'action économique et les
transports
je pense que ça va dans le sens des
préoccupations des franciliens puisque
l'étude d'opinion qui est paru dia ou
avant-hier dit première préoccupation
même dans le cadre de la campagne aja
les attentats deuxième préoccupation
l'action économique et on vient de voir
les chiffres et des chauffages du
chômage qui explose et troisième
préoccupation les transports en termes
d'économie création d'une banque
publique régionale d'investissement pour
aider ces entreprises c'est à dire
monsieur s'ils ont eu fort un peu plus
de temps mais j'ai une expérience assez
ancien vous l'avez dit tout à la de
conseiller régional et notamment j'ai
toujours chez g dans les commissions
d'action économique
j'ai toujours été désolés que les
régions ne prennent pas vraiment le
problème à bras le corps elles peuvent
le faire elles sont toujours rester au
milieu du gué et mon idée est de mettre
une partie de l'action économique de la
région est desservi la région dans un
organisme qui aurait les droits et les
devoirs d'un organisme bancaire mais qui
serais tu as une banque publique et dont
les décisions d'individualisation de
crédit seraient toujours voté
démocratiquement par la commission
permanente du conseil régional c'est ce
qui est fait à l'heure actuelle ça
poserait pas de problèmes techniques et
je pense qu'une fusion beaucoup plus
efficace notamment pour les
entrepreneurs notamment pour les petits
entrepreneurs les moyens entrepreneurs
qui ont toujours de très graves
problèmes de trésorerie dans leurs cinq
ans leurs cinq premières années
d'existence et sans risque financier
pour autant pour la région si l'on est
bien entendu et avec encore moins de
risques financiers qu'à l'heure actuelle
puisque encore une fois nous aurions les
droits et obligations d'un organisme
bancaire
on connaît bien la banque ils peuvent
être en même temps très réactif et en
même temps très prudent à l'heure
actuelle les banques que nous
connaissons ils ne sont plus que
prudents et ils ne sont pas du tout
réactif la la région avec ses 350
millions d'euros annuels consacrés à
l'action économique on peut être
beaucoup plus efficace une dernière
question puisque nous arrivons au bout
de ce quart d'heure d'entretien une
dernière question pour savoir si vous
êtes élu si comme marion maréchal-le pen
dans la région paca vous allait
supprimer les subventions plannings
familiaux alors que les plannings
familiaux sont en charge de l'éducation
sexuelle qui lutte pour le droit à la
contraception à la banque de monsieur
cette question n'a pas du tout du tout
été abordée dans mon programme et pour
une bonne et simple raison c'est que je
sais que ça ne fait plus du tout partie
des préoccupations des franciliens et je
crois des français en général donc vous
qu'on paie pas les subventions
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention des
coupes et encore une fois mon devoir en
tant que responsables politiques et
candidats ceux de m'attacher aux
préoccupations actuelles de mes contrats
de compatriotes
la question de la contraception excusez
moi en 2015 c'est pas quelque chose qui
soucis défensifs
les franciliennes donc je n'en parle pas
donc la proposition la décision de
marion maréchal-le pen s'était pas
opportun je pense que je ne sais pas je
cours merci balle ronde saint-just tête
de liste ile de france pour vous rendre
nationale 13 listes je le rappelle se
présente dans notre région interviews
reportages sur les différentes
formations que nous avons pu leur
consacrer à revoir en replay sur notre
site internet
retour sur le plateau en direct si vous
nous suivez aujourd'hui à mardi 1er
décembre j'accueille est à présent
emmanuel loevenbruck bonsoir tête de
liste et yveline de nous citoyens votre
ambition c'est de redonner la parole au
peuple
finalement face aux politiques qui ont
échoué le nom de la formation c'est
d'ailleurs une réponse au fameux mois
président de françois hollande pendant
la campagne présidentielle de 2012 on
vous situez où sur l'échiquier politique
ministère de l'intérieur dirais plutôt à
droite mais ça vous pouvez y ait un
recours pour ça d'ailleurs parce que en
france on est obligé d'être de droite on
est obligé d'être de gauche
mais c'est bien embêtant quand on n'est
ni l'un ni l'autre parce que vous êtes
plutôt proche des idées de la droite
classique - une fiscalité moins de
dépenses publiques incitation à
l'entrepreneuriat on est de droite
oui disons qu'on est on est dans le
réalisme effectivement quand on voit la
france aujourd'hui quand on voit le site
du conseil régional j'ai regardé la
homepage et j'ai vu quoi un moteur de
recherche pour les aides et j'ai vu tout
un menu pour les haines
mais je n'ai rien vu pour le
développement de la région et ça c'est
un vrai problème parce que on pourra pas
être solidaire et pourtant c'est une de
nos valeurs et la première sans être
prospère j'ai continué sur la
présentation rapide de votre mouvement
nous citoyens mouvement est né en
juillet 2013 sur l'initiative de
l'entrepreneur denis payre six mois plus
tard il revendique plus de 8000
adhérents présentent trente-trois listes
aux municipales
un an plus tard douze mille adhérents 20
binôme aux élections départementales et
aujourd'hui après le départ celui qui
aurait été aussi votre président pendant
un an c'est jean marie cavada vous
présenter des candidats dans trois
régions
c'est un deuxième départ en fait pour
votre malgré tout jeune formation
alors je vais parler d'un troisième
départ et rectifier le fait que jean
marie cavada effectivement a été
président pendant quelques mois et
aujourd'hui il est parti du mouvement
on a considéré que l'adn de départ
n'était pas présent chez jean marie
cavada divergences de point de vue il ya
une divergence et donc nous sommes des
candidats sont aujourd'hui en lice pour
trouver un nouveau président pour la
mi-janvier à ce ce mouvement aujourd'hui
les sondages vous créditent d'environ 0
5% vous avez du mal à vous faire
entendre dans cette campagne
oui oui évidemment on a du mal à se
faire entendre
on voit souvent les quatre partis
majeurs qui effectivement ont droit à
des lignes de deux programmes et puis
nous on est en et derrière on a du mal
aussi parce que financièrement diffuser
une profession de foi dans les
enveloppes de propagande
il n'y en a pas ça nous coûte 57 mille
euros et nous n'avions pas 57 mille
euros et d une certaine d'un certain
côté on est content parce que quand on
voit la coop 21 quand on voit ces 200
millions de de deux pages qui sont
diffusées
on se dit qu'il faudrait peut-être
diffuser cinquante mille cent mille
exemplaires et puis le reste en
numérique c'est tellement simple à la
maison avec j'ai une famille nombreuse
j'ai reçu cinq enveloppes
j'aurais pu recevoir peut-être deux ou
une enfin j'aurais pu l'indiquer en tout
cas sur un site très facilement les
attentats ça a rendu aussi compliquer
votre communication vous êtes moins
audible parce qu'effectivement on l'aimé
partis traditionnels ont repris les dits
traditionnels mais en tout cas
historiques et ont repris la parole
écoutez il ya la partie média et puis
moi j'étais dans la rue j'y suis depuis
trois semaines ils nous étions les seuls
et nous n'avons eu que des gens qui nous
ont dit écoutez oui c'est bien d'être là
parce que vous êtes différent vous nous
représentez et donc
votre réponse aux attentats c'est une
riposte citoyenne oui un petit peu les
choses
alors la riposte citoyenne ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que si vous voulez
faire une ligne maginot en france on
sait ce que ça a donné
c'est ça marchera pas comment on pourra
réussir être plus en sécurité en france
en faisant en sorte que les citoyens se
prennent en main alors se prennent en
main ça veut dire utiliser les nouvelles
technologies se veut dire aussi est dans
des nouveaux modèles sociaux et à partir
de là on fait en sorte qu'ils aient
davantage d'unité nationale davantage
d'informations de connaissances que les
choses ont pu aller les chercher à la
source qu'on ne soit pas dans des
pensées uniques et qu'on apprenne à
mieux vivre ensemble et à comprendre le
monde musulman avec toutes ces
disparités ses excès énorme mais aussi
ces gens ça et moi je vais aux mureaux
de temps en temps je vais dans la cité
des mureaux ma famille il va plus
souvent que moi mais nous avons la
chance d'avoir pendant les vacances des
familles musulmanes mais c'est un grande
joie d'avoir cette diversité puis de
pouvoir vivre ensemble il faut plus de
diable aujourd'hui on a mis de côté
l'idée du dialogue et enterré c'est
l'idée du dialogue j'espère pas qu'elle
n'est pas enterré je pense que
d'ailleurs le monde musulman a un petit
peu à s'organiser à à lever la tête pour
dire non on essaie surtout pas ça notre
j'ai vu sur youtube des trucs
enfin des dégâts de la cité qui disent
on arrête de peut-être avoir certains
comportements qui laisse penser qu'ils
qu'on est un peu tous pareil quand il ya
un amalgame mais non nous enfin moi je
pense vraiment que il faut mieux comme
elle connaître ce monde qui fait partie
de la réalité française
j'aimerais qu'on parle de vos
propositions pour la région ile de
france a à présent l'île de france une
surdoué qui s'ignorent qu'est ce qu'il
manque justement pour découvrir son
talent abbas et c'est mon métier c'est
coach c'est à dire que je suis là pour
faire changer et faire en sorte que
les potentiels se ressortent et je vois
des choses magnifiques mais c'est qu'on
fasse du coaching au niveau de la région
des personnes alors qu'on évite de des
mandats chez les politiques trop long
est-ce qu'on le voit tout de suite c'est
compliqué il n'y a pas je fais de la
petite depuis deux ans j'ai été élu et
c'est pour ça que je porte je c'est un
signe parce que je pense que c'est
important si tous les élus porte et
c'est un signe on a parlé d'un drapeau
national très bien mais moi j'aimerais
bien que françois hollande est aussi en
permanence sa mentonnière le rappelle
qu'il a été élu par des citoyens que
tous les politiques soient dans la même
idée
donc bon voilà deux mandats consécutifs
pas plus et après on repart dans la
vraie vie c'est comme ça qu'on aura du
bon sens et qu'on est là on lui dira je
n'avais pas une profession évidemment et
dames mais évidemment c'est tellement
sclérosant mais deux ans en politique
m'ont montré que le politique est là
pour être réélu par intérêt alors ça
veut pas dire que tous les politiques
sont des pourris
non mais ils sont tous intéressés à
partir du moment où il reste en
politique
et là ça devient des combines ça devient
des quelques ça veut dire qu'à nos
citoyens tous ceux qui s'y engagent
savent déjà quand ils vous repartez un
arbitre m oui je moi je sais trés je
sais très bien j'en ai pris pour 12 ans
parce que je crois que en politique
c'est pas toujours la joie mais j'ai
envie de le faire pour mes enfants j'ai
huit enfants et j'ai envie de le faire
pour eux mais pour elle utilise enfin et
je sais que dans dix ans j'aurais
plusieurs petits enfants et je
m'occuperai d'eux ça c'est pour l'aspect
du de l'engagement des citoyens que vous
représentez avec cette formation
politique sur la question des transports
parce que ça c'est une compétence de la
région très clair il ya souvent une
surenchère de propositions quelles sont
vos propositions il ya un axe le
particulier autour du transport
d'éducation aussi des jeunes
oui alors moi je regarde les adolescents
enfin les jeunes les jeunes majeurs
comment ils font aujourd'hui mais la
voiture individuelle ça n'est plus leur
modèle ils partagent ils font du blabla
car pour 20 km pour 50 km je me suis mis
au blabla quart mais c'est formidable
donc l'autopartage
le toutes ces choses là sont
essentielles et quand je vois une
proposition de valérie pécresse
complètement démagogique de payer le
permis conduire aux jeunes franciliens
mais enfin mais ça coûte 100 millions
d'euros par an et ça ne répond pas à une
demande concon alors oui qu'on paye le
permis de conduire si on s'engage à
faire tendre km en blabla car avec trois
personnes dans sa voix du covoiturage
derrière voila voila mais vous savez là
seul endroit aujourd'hui on a une marge
de liberté dans le transport parisien
c'est pas compliqué il suffit d'ouvrir
ses yeux vous mettez sur un pont et vous
regardez voiture passait il ya des
mètres cubes dans les voitures et bien
on n'a qu'à remplir ses voitures de
mètres cubes et de personnes et puis et
puis on roulera très très bien et non il
faut et puis vous savez j trail sur le
scot le schéma de cohérence territoriale
ont reproduit les mêmes schémas on ne
prend absolument pas en compte les
nouveaux comportements des jeunes et moi
je peux vous pariez que dans dix ans
sa saveur ça sera peut-être pas mieux
parce que ya pas que des jeunes qui
prennent les transports mais on
commencera à voir une inflexion
l'éducation à la base de toute façon
pour avoir une évolution par la suite
vous parlez de la de l'homogénéité de ce
territoire de politiques territoriales
dans le cadre du grand paris justement
votre vision c'est plutôt un esprit
village aussi garder la rue urbanité
nous sommes ici dans la seconde couronne
concerne directement pour département
des yvelines faut garder cet esprit
village un peu et pas tout sacrifier la
vision du grand paris
l'organisme a débridé je fais du
tractage tous les matins aux entrées des
bouches de métro aux fins de rer en
l'occurrence je vois je vois le stress
je vois aussi en coaching le stress je
vois la façon de vivre aujourd'hui des
franciliens sait on pourrait faire
vraiment d étude très intéressante en
fonction début ce qui arrive est de voir
comment les gens sont déjà compris mais
selon le temps qu'ils ont mis dans le
bus
les transports se sont allongés de 30 %
en quinze ans donc oui cet esprit
village il faut il faut aimer alors ça
veut dire que l'emploi il faut aussi le
savoir le mettre au bon endroit
il faut savoir travailler à distance un
mot je travaille à distance tous les
jours on a on est connecté on a tout ce
qu'il faut donc revoyons tous nos
modèles mais avec les politiques qui
font ça depuis 10 20 ans décidée elle
change pas que vous
ça vous fait beaucoup de travail parce
qu'il faut tout reprendre à zéro
aujourd'hui satisfaits du travail mais
en même temps si vous voulez on peut le
faire avec méthode quand on voit les
quatre les catalogues de la redoute que
sont le programme d écologie europe
ecologie les verts le programme m de
valérie pécresse
mais écoutez et hiérarchise ont un petit
peu tout ça mettons des tarifs en face
de tout ça et puis le père noël est pour
bientôt là mais franchement non il faut
être sérieux on prend les choses
importantes et puis après les choses
secondaires et en enlève les choses
démagogie une toute dernière question
très rapidement la dimension
participative qui était au coeur de
votre démarche
aussi cette élection c'est une aussi une
nouvelle pierre pour 2017 que ceux sur
les législatives que ce soit la
présidentielle bien sûr on est on est
assez débutant en politique donc on
apprends moi j'ai beaucoup appris en un
mois et effectivement sont des galops
d'essai pour peut-être des élections
législatives peut-être même aussi pour
les présidentielles on verra enrayée il
faut beaucoup d'argent pour une
présidentielle merci emmanuelle han van
bree qui est donc le trio liste yvelines
pour nous citoyens en ile de france
merci à vous c'est la fin de ce set 8
politique n'oubliez pas d'aller voter et
dimanche nous reviendrons sur l'ensemble
des résultats au cours d'une édition
spéciale lundi dès 18h30 en direct les
formations qui sont qualifiés au second
tour viendront aussi débattre au cours
de la semaine sur notre plateau très
bonne soirée